all right well I'll just pull this up
because uh I love the story maybe since
Friday they've actually dipped 2.34 oh
yeah so they there there's a that looks
like I bet you right there's a visual
problem
I was gonna use some logic here and I'm
gonna say that that is when the campaign
happened yeah but it's not apocalyptic
because all they did was do a
partnership can and as of today it's up
like point two percent after hours is
0.2 percent but since last Friday they
uh okay so Friday then Tuesday the 30th
it was at 33 it's dropped 2.34 percent
so it's actually it's low was down uh it
was like almost two three dollars
yeah their Bud light's way down I want
to screenshot it and put like one of
those progress Flags like right where it
drops and then be like boom so we put it
out on the 27th so we put the article on
the 27th so yeah it would have been
Friday Thursday or Friday so when people
are reading the new there it is boom
yeah that Tuesday and that was uh
yeah dang Tuesday's when the drop this
was this was after and it makes sense
because Monday was Memorial day yeah was
there no stock trading on Memorial Day I
I think so it goes Friday to Tuesday so
it drops right oh that's crazy right now
when people are back from the from the
holiday it's the queer Theory effect
boys and girls wow I I call it I call it
the Bud Light effect I'm all about
impact investment uh if you do it right
this is just like a battle of wills
because like Tim what you did with the
uh Times Square uh Banner the Times
Square Billboards that was impact
investment that wasn't didn't make the
company any money necessarily off the
top it just brought brand awareness to
what you want to be but that's not
impact investment it's a form of it it's
it but no it's just you're right it's
advertising it's not technically if if
we put investment if we put up an ad
that said something like you know woke
is bad yeah that's an impact investment
yeah yeah yeah you're right we just put
a Billboards I was like watch the show
it's great but even that like
uh using your own personal money or your
company's money to promote things you
like I mean that seems righteous on its
heel it's just a matter of if you like
psycho stuff then
you know maybe
do you think should it be illegal for
business owners to spend their
businesses money I don't think so I mean
I think it should be I think it should
be illegal for places like HRC to create
a whoa credit score that people have to
abide by if they want to compete who's
giving HR look at this no no so again
that's that's all based off BlackRock
and Vanguard who's who's running the the
ESP scores because that feeds into the
ESG score what is this look at this
shelf yeah so Friday it's here
Tuesday because of the holiday weekend
it dropped two bucks right away five
percent down in five days they didn't
sell as much as they thought they would
on Monday for the holiday apparently
look at this it's so bad at the start of
the year they were at 60 bucks and now
they're at 53. the power of the people
it's going to keep going down like I
can't imagine anyone Look what comes out
so you've got the summer months coming
up you've got great reports and then
March March 31st is the day before Dylan
Mulvaney there was a quick sell I
remember when it went down and here's
what I think I think people saw it go
down and went boycotts never work I'm
gonna buy the dip so it goes back up a
little bit and then it didn't stop and
now the people who are holding it are
like okay we can't hold on to this we
gotta sell it there's literally no sane
reason to hold on to a stock that is
doubling down on on why it's crashing
which is
perhaps the woke don't care that they
will destroy this Company's stock
because Anheuser-Busch stock is not just
Bud Light Bud Light is one product of
hundreds
but this company is has said we we know
you're angry this what did the CSA we
didn't want to be involved in a
conversation that was divisive let's
give hundreds of thousands of more
dollars to more of these organizations
they know they are ripping their country
to shreds so if you're someone's still
holding the stock
that's the definition of insanity the
internet definition of insanity they are
holding their hand to a to a glass top
stove and going like yeah but give it a
it'll stop burning in a second that's
the sun cost fallacy well I mean look at
the top of this chart if you if you were
an investor and you paid attention to a
show like this and you went what's this
there's a there's a controversy with Bud
Light I'm gonna sell all my stock it's
peaked it's really high and I'm gonna
buy a company that does beer that's not
controversial and you invested in say
Coors you are up 20 yeah or something
like that if you said and this will all
blow over you are down 10.84 this year
and from the peak you're down way more I
think 15 it's probably more than 15 to
be honest because that's just the past
month and we're looking at two months so
you're down from 66 to 53.
yeah and that in that Gap it has to do
with the initial sell-off happened I
think a lot of people thought that you
know there's going to be a pump of you
know ESG money into this into it to get
them past the controversy but the
controversy never passed and so now
you're seeing the effect of the boycott
actually taking taking place because now
it's like hey this isn't going away we
don't have enough money to save this
stock and so that's the difference
between like sales and profit in
companies and financial institutions of
money of companies because that's where
the stock market and companies don't
necessarily match up with you know a
stock price is not indicative of profits
necessarily
I imagine that they were shutter they
were feeling the shake of pain maybe
there was an influx of ESG money for
this first month but that they were they
were realizing for the first month what
they're gonna have to cut like
everything is is is falling now so and
then you don't start to see it you know
they tried their best to kind of mask it
with rebuys of stock and stuff in the
past six months Target is down 20 in the
past six months Walmart is down 3.79 so
something's interesting because you
brought something up that's really
interesting you said look at this first
dip and it's like oh but then they said
boycotts don't work yep so that's
interesting because it does do Target do
they have they don't okay so that came
afterwards so I wonder if they're like
okay boycotts work now yeah exactly so
you take a look at this you look at
Target and right around the time the
controversy started May 17th that from
160 all the way down to 130 30 bucks off
their share price and there was no dip
yeah ever so New York mag wrote this
article and they said when I heard about
the Bud Light boycott I said it's not
gonna work it never works and then it
did and now people are scared like uh oh
why
get there's there's no one here and no
one online can give me a legitimate
reason as to why you would intentionally
hold a stock facing a massive
controversy when you can with a swipe of
your phone sell the stock buy any other
company not controversial wait and then
buy it back later on if you really
wanted to doesn't make sense nothing it
doesn't make sense at all so I can only
imagine there there are people who are
holding on to the stock uh for a b and
both who don't really pay attention and
have a diverse portfolio in their like
you know stocks go up and down I'm gonna
but I wouldn't be surprised if
seeing it's a really great point you
made that Target doesn't have the rebuy
people buying the dip because people are
like nope I'm getting out of this
exactly I think people are waking up and
the fact that the stocks are is
incredible I wouldn't be surprised if
come next week ab and Bev is in the 40s
and then welcome it imagine being down
30 some odd percent on on the stock that
you bought and still thinking that you
can hold it's like it's like a gambler's
fallacy almost I think you're right
though is most people when they put
their stuff in like mutual funds and and
all that stuff they're not thinking
about that and their investor is right
doing it so
why is my 401k yeah what's going on and
so you have to go look and see what your
mutual funds are invested in if they're
invested in Anheuser-Busch you might
want to go uh tell your
but that would also be possibly a
lawsuit against you know the financial
institution that's holding the mutual
fund because they're not completing
their fiduciary duty to get out of a bad
stock
I think there's there's serious lawsuit
potential yeah the the there are
safeguards in place for stockholders
and
the institutions may be captured Bud
Light a b and Bev may be captured by
woke Psychopaths but there is still a
mechanism to defend those from someone
it could really it could be really
simple it could be using Wellness to
intentionally destroy a company for some
reason and I wonder this
who has short has shorted but but suck
because when Bud here's what I think
when I'm when I see Bud Light say we're
going to sponsor more Pride events and
give more money I'm like okay
who at that company told a friend to bot
to short to buy put options because
they're like hey we lost 30 because of
this and then someone goes 30 30 of your
sales that's a lot of put up so yep so
this this boycott's huge so what do you
think in a week you could lose 10 if you
did it again it could be a 10 drop I'll
put a hundred grand inputs and then you
do it again boom we get a 10 return I
would be investigating that but of
course the doj is fairly woke they
probably won't but I'm willing to bet
someone somewhere
but put options on bud
because you know we were talking about
this before we were like man we read the
news all day every day why don't we
invest in what we talk about because we
knew this was happening before it
happened and I was like I don't know I
think the Stock's going to drop and it
was it was fine people were buying the
dip I could have bought a bunch of puts
and be like oh yeah I bought you know
but I didn't I don't do any of that
stuff but I wonder how many people
watching probably did how much money did
they make yeah this is I have a very
important question is the Paul Pelosi
stock tracker back on Twitter
because that is where all of our answers
lie my friends I think there is a woke
index okay yes that's uh so there's um
someone go check that and put it in the
super chats there had been a lot of
people have been pointing out that
companies that embrace wokeness are not
going to make money because they're
embracing ideology over meritocracy
so there have been people who have
targeted these companies for shortage to
short them because they're like if they
outright publicly say they care more
about ideology over actually being a
company they're going to lose a ton of
money it's a GameStop but not because
it's not like they're not intentionally
tanking the stock
yeah interesting thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time